au fond ce que vous nous rappeler c'est
qu'être artiste c'est signé non être
considérés non non non non non être
artiste est un égoïste être négocié stss
et rejoint ma nouvelle théorie que l'ego
est très important quand je regarde les
films à la télé sur les animaux sur les
singes les jeux les coléoptères sur les
planches et chaude je m'aperçois que
tout ce qui est vivant contient de lego
parce que tout ce qu'ils vivent on vous
cherche se reproduire et tout ce qu'ils
cherchent à se reproduire contient du
code contient de lego dans ma théorie
légaux ces essais et essai s est agrandi
là mais qu'une petite partie de la
théorie de lego lego de bernac des
artistes c'est d'une toute petite chose
l'ego des nationalistes légaux des
présidents dès que le maquereau l'égard
de madame de madame de trempe les gosses
aussi et on s'aperçoit que le monde des
fables et kiko dgo dgo vous avez fait
une théorie de lego qui est devenu un
livre d'ailleurs on va voir la création
et de l'ego d'ailleurs j'aime bien
théorie de lego voilà
[Rires]
[Musique]